[Musique]
cette photographie a été prise par Thas
peschac qui est un des photographes star
de national géographique depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant qui
documente non seulement la
vie de la biodiversité marine mais aussi
tous ceux qui vogu autour de la mer ici
on voit un plongeur en apnus et c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel il n'est pas simplement en
plongé il est en apnée et tout d'un coup
il a été entouré par une danse de carang
à gros yeux qui sont des gros poissons
assez impressionnants ça a été pris dans
un récif coralien qui a été préservé de
la pêche il y a plusieurs années et où
la biomasse a plus que doublé en
seulement quelques années la vie a
retrouvé son chemin depuis que cet
espace a été protégé c'est une des
missions de national geéographique de
protéger la biodiversité marine on a un
programme qui s'appelle Chistine qui
depuis presque 15 ans à a permis de
financer 41 expéditions pour quadriller
un petit peu la manière dont les océans
fonctionnent et avec le concours des
communautés locales des peuples premiers
et des gouvernements de protéger plus de
6,6 millions de kilomè Carr à ce
[Musique]
jour